can you name like just start rattling  off some old brown starting quarterbacks  Bernie Vinnie Brady Quinn Annika Wallace  that Ken Dorsey you got Colt McCoy oh  you got Johnny Manziel yes oh my gosh so  many we got couch got Johnny Manziel  uh head coach of the Jaguars or maybe  the offensive coordinator for the bills  there's a bunch of box quarterbacks out  there yeah looks like Daniel's saying  Brandon no Brandon weeded yes we had one  year we had like eight quarterbacks um  soda's not a Browns fan can't even name  five people on this list Baker Mayfield  Ace Kingdom this  Jeff Garcia Johnny Football got Brandon  weeded Eric Anderson we got Jake  delhomes I can't even name all I've  watched every Browns game my whole life